PRIYA PATEL: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to Cloud OnAir, live
webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Priya Patel.
And today, we'll be talking
about transforming your content
management strategy
with Box and G Suite.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So let's get started.
My name is Priya Patel.
And I'm the Group Product
Marketing Manager at Box,
focused on our partnerships
and integrations.
I'm excited to be joined shortly
by John Lake, Vice President
of Enterprise Applications
from DocuSign,
who is going to join
us live for a Q&A
to learn about how DocuSign
is using both Box and G Suite
today, as well as the Box
for G Suite integration,
to be more productive.
By way of agenda today,
we're going to be covering--
I know it's a mixed
audience of folks
who might be familiar
with Box and folks
who aren't as familiar.
So I want to spend some time
giving a brief introduction
into Box.
And then, of course, we want
to give an overview of the Box
for G Suite integration
and provide a live demo
so you can see it in action.
And then we're going to bring
John Lake up from DocuSign
to do a customer
spotlight Q&A. And we also
want to make sure that we have
time for audience questions
as well.
So starting with Box, I
want to just kick this off
by talking about
the mission of Box.
Over the past 13 years, we've
heard from many companies
like Nike, Coca-Cola, and GE.
And they've all said
a very similar thing,
which is that they want
to be more efficient.
They want to be faster.
But sometimes technology
stands in the way.
And so, at Box, our
mission is very simple--
to power how the
world works together.
And we work with
companies around the globe
of every industry--
as you can see here, even some
of the most highly regulated
industries like the public
government, financial services
companies, and companies
in the health care space.
We have 87,000 customers today.
And we're really
excited to be helping
to drive digital transformation
for all of these customers.
Digital transformation is on
every company's mind today.
It's incredibly important to
be agile in an increasingly
competitive, fast-paced
business environment.
And how we collaborate
and manage our information
is really at the core of
digital transformation.
Because information touches
every business process,
it runs through every
employee at a company,
and is incredibly critical
to getting business done.
But unfortunately, the
way that our information
is managed today is fragmented.
And this is because of the
way that content strategies
have evolved in a very
fragmented way over time.
So starting in the '90s, you
had file shares, network drives,
even physical media,
going to the post office
to transmit content.
And enterprise content
management solutions
such a Documentum and
SharePoint and OpenText
evolved to provide one central
repository for your content
that could be easily
searched and indexed.
But these were not built
for the end user in mind.
And because they
weren't as easy to use,
they never evolved beyond a
few departmental use cases.
And then, with the
rise in mobility
and the need to be
able to work on the go,
consumer file sync
and share tools
that were very easy
to use and intuitive,
such as Dropbox and
Microsoft OneDrive cropped up
as well to meet the new
demands of the workforce.
And then, at the same time,
application development
became popular again.
And you have a lot of companies
building their own custom
applications on platforms such
as AWS and Microsoft Azure.
And we've also seen a rise
of line of business cloud
applications such as
Salesforce and Workday,
new cloud tools that enhance
collaboration, such a Slack
and Workplace by Facebook.
And all of this means
that your content
is fragmented across all
of these different systems
and applications today.
For those dialed
in, I'd like you
to just take a
look at this slide
and think about how many
different applications you're
using at your
organization today,
such as those listed here.
And you're probably
using multiple today.
So what if you had
one platform that
worked for all of your content?
That's Cloud Content
Management from Box.
It's one platform,
born in the cloud that
enables seamless
and secure internal
and external collaboration,
provides a single source
of truth for content across
your best-of-breed applications
because it integrates seamlessly
across your applications.
It automates business workflows
across the extended enterprise,
leverages advanced
machine learning
and artificial
intelligence technologies
from all the major vendors,
including Google Cloud
Platform, to help automate
business workflows
and provide security and
compliance for every industry
and geo without
sacrificing simplicity.
I'd like to give an overview of
what the Box platform provides.
At the core, you have
the content capabilities,
the ability to seamlessly
collaborate internally
and externally across
teams, automate workflows,
apply machine learning and
intelligence to your content,
but there is a lot more
to that that Box offers.
Box has several
native applications.
I'll just touch upon
a few listed here.
Box Drive, which enables
you to stream your Box
files on your desktop to imitate
a network drive experience--
so taking up very
little space, but being
able to easily access your
files in a very familiar way.
Box Relay, which provides
workflow capabilities that
are very end-user focused,
very simple for the end
user to set up to automate
manual, repeatable workflows.
Box Notes, which is
a really easy way
for teams to
collaborate in real time
when they're in meetings to
capture notes as well as action
items.
And Box Capture, which enables
you to take photos on the go
when you're at work.
This is great for
mobile field teams
with all of those photos
stored securely into Box
versus on your personal device.
Those are just some
examples of Box apps.
And as I mentioned, Box
integrates seamlessly
across a multitude of tools.
We have over 1,400 cloud
application integrations today.
Of course, G Suite, which
we're going to focus on today,
but we also integrate
with Office 365,
messaging and collaboration
tools such as Slack,
Workplace by Facebook, line
of business applications,
such as Salesforce
and ServiceNow,
as well as e-signature solutions
such as DocuSign and Adobe
Sign--
we're excited to
have John join us
later on to talk a bit more
about what DocuSign does--
as well as workflow and
business process management
tools, such as Nintex and Pega.
And then Box has a
robust APIs and SDKs
that enable companies to build
on the Box platform with Box
as the content layer powering
applications such as client
portals, when you
have lots of documents
that you're sharing between
internal and external parties--
this is a very popular use
case for wealth management--
mobile field support for
companies that have a big
employee base in the field,
custom digital process--
this is great for
marketing teams
to easily share content across
internal and external parties.
And then I really want to
highlight the last piece, which
is important, which
is that all of this
resides on a layer of
security and compliance
that makes this all safe
to reside in the cloud.
So Box, starting
with Insights, Box
has over 80 different
reports that we
offer to IT admins to get really
granular reporting into how
content is being shared and
managed across the organization
and outside.
With Box Zones, we offer
the ability for companies
to select where their data
is stored to comply with data
residency requirements.
We offer multiple layers
of protection and DLP--
also, from the
governance perspective,
the ability to apply legal holds
and apply retention policies
on your content, on your
files, on your folders.
And then, through
our KeySafe product,
we allow customers to
manage their own encryption
keys for ultimate privacy.
And so I hope this gives
you a sense for what
the Box platform provides--
pretty robust capabilities
beyond just kind
of sharing and
managing your content,
but providing a variety
of apps, integrations,
and a platform offering
to be able to do more
with your content.
So now I'd like to dive into the
Box for G Suite integration--
why we're all here today.
A little bit of
background about Box--
Box and Google have
been strategic partners
for a few years now.
And we're working
together to transform
the way organizations
collaborate and do work
in the cloud.
And we're excited to be
deepening our partnership
through new
integrations over time.
So we launched our Hangouts Chat
integration earlier this year.
Docs, Sheets, and Slides, which
is the focus of today's webinar
is publicly available
today through beta
and will be available
generally, to the public,
by the end of this year.
And I'll provide more details
on how to get this integration.
We're also going to be
launching our Gmail integration
by end of this year as well.
We announced this and
shared it at Google Next
a couple of months ago.
And I'll also be providing more
details on that integration
later on.
We also integrate with Google
Cloud and the Google Cloud
Platform to provide Google
Machine Learning capabilities
to Box customers
to apply to content
to automate business processes.
So Box for G Suite--
just by way of an overview
of what this provides,
we're bringing the
rich experience
of Google Docs, Sheets, and
Slides directly into Box.
And so this means that you can
seamlessly leverage Google's
familiar editing
experience from within Box,
so you can create a new Google
Docs, Sheets, and Slides
while ensuring your
content is organized
and easily discoverable.
You can collaborate in
real time with Google's
rich real-time
editing capabilities
in Google Sheets
and Slides, being
able to see edits that
are happening in real time
with all changes
instantly saved into Box,
and you can maintain
enterprise-level standards--
so ensuring your content meets
the security, compliance,
and governance requirements
of any industry
with our robust
security infrastructure.
So in terms of key features
that I'll be highlighting
in the demo shortly--
you can easily create new
Docs, Sheets, and Slides
with any edits that you make to
these documents instantly saved
into Box.
And you can also see
version history in Box
like you can with any other
document that's managed in Box.
And you get the robust
security that I mentioned,
our governance
capabilities, to any files
that are saved in Box.
And John from DocuSign
will be joining us shortly
to provide a live
customer viewpoint.
But I wanted to highlight one
of our other joint customers
of the Box for G
Suite integration--
Indiana University.
G Suite is widely used
across the education space.
And they're using
Box for G Suite
across 100,000 faculty and
students to share syllabi
and to manage
educational content.
And so with that, I'm
going to go into the demo.
So this is what the Box
experience looks like.
Over here, you can easily
search for any files.
You can search by
file type, by the date
it's uploaded, by title.
On the left, you can easily
access your recent files.
You can easily see notifications
if someone left comments
for you to look at a document.
All your Box Notes
would be stored here.
You can also favorite
documents so you can easily
refer to them.
And then, over here, you have--
so I'm in a Launch folder.
I'm in marketing.
And I often collaborate with
my product manager counterparts
in this folder.
And so I can see
everyone who's here.
I can easily share the folder.
Depending on who I
want to share it with,
I can edit permission
levels, stop them
from being able to edit,
maybe just enabling them
to view or preview or download.
So Box offers pretty granular
permission capabilities there.
And I'm going to go ahead and
go into a product spec document
because my team, I
know, has been editing.
You can see here, they're in
the doc editing it right now.
And I know that they
left me some comments.
So let me go ahead
and go into this.
I also want to highlight, you
can easily download, share.
You can share documents in
Slack and other integrations
directly from here.
But I'm going to go ahead and
open this into Google Docs.
So here's this
product spec document.
I just want to
take a look at it.
I know that the team
left some comments.
OK.
They're working on
prioritizing some features.
Oh, great.
This functionality is something
that I've been waiting for.
"That's great.
Thanks for the update."
Ooh.
It's all in caps.
And then you can
resolve comments.
And then if I make any edits,
you can see here at the top,
"All changes are saved in Box."
And so this is really important.
When you enable this
integration, any documents that
are created from within Box--
any Google Docs, Sheets,
or Slides documents are saved
in a Box, not in Google Drive.
And so that's really
important to enable
that one central repository
for all of your content.
So I'm going to go ahead and
close out of this document,
go back into Box.
And I also want to
share one other thing
that Box provides,
which is that you're
able to actually take Office
files-- so this is an XLS file,
an Excel file.
And I actually choose to
open this with Google Sheets.
So what it's going to
do is convert that Excel
file into Google Sheets.
I can make edits.
Let's just say I
want to change this.
And all of those edits
will be saved back
to the original file format.
So they'll be saved
back into Excel.
And so you can see here, "A
new version was just uploaded.
Would you like to
refresh the page?"
And then here, I'll be able
to access the latest version.
And there's been
27 versions saved.
You can access all of
your version history here.
And then the last
thing I want to share
is that this is where you can
actually create any new Google
Docs, Sheets, Slides,
and Sheets files,
as well as any Office files.
So I just want to show what
the experience looks like.
If I create a new
document, New Doc, whoo--
It'll immediately launch.
And any edits I make
in this document
will be managed and saved
securely back into Box.
This is going a bit
slow, but yeah--
so you can see how you can also
create [? and add ?] new files
as well.
So with that, I'm going to
go back into the slides.
I also want to highlight that,
in addition to our integration
with Docs, Sheets, and
Slides, Box for Gmail
will be coming soon by the
end of this year as well.
And what this offers
is the ability
to access Box content
from within Gmail.
You can change
permissions to any files,
you can attach Box links
directly into emails.
And then when you get an
email that has an attachment,
you can save that
attachment directly into Box
and select which folder
you'd like to save that to--
so just making it super
seamless to work in the tools
that you're working
in every day,
but ensuring that all of your
content is managed in Box.
And so with that,
I'd love to bring up
John Lake from DocuSign
for a customer Q&A. Great.
John, thank you for
joining us today.
JOHN LAKE: Well,
thanks for inviting me.
Happy to be here.
PRIYA PATEL: Can you tell us
a little bit about DocuSign
and your role there?
JOHN LAKE: Absolutely.
Yeah, DocuSign has been
around since about 2003.
I think we are largely known
as an e-signature company.
But we're also
helping to fuel a lot
of the digital
transformation initiatives
through our system of agreements
where we're helping customers
prepare or sign, but
also act and manage
on the content that drives
their digital transactions.
PRIYA PATEL: Great.
And can you tell me a little
bit about the unique challenges
that you face from
an IT standpoint?
JOHN LAKE: Yeah.
DocuSign's a
hypergrowth company.
We have been growing
rapidly, largely,
over the last four
to five years,
although we've been
around for a little while.
A tremendous influx of employees
over the last couple of years--
I think a recent metric I
saw internally was about 65%
of our employees
have been at DocuSign
for two to three years.
So very diverse, globally
distributed workforce.
We're in about-- we have 15
offices distributed globally.
So I think the challenges
that come with hypergrowth
are the challenges
that we're facing.
PRIYA PATEL: Absolutely.
And how do these trends
impact the IT tools
that you select for DocuSign?
JOHN LAKE: Again, a lot
of influx of new people--
hypergrowth means
that there's been
a lot of organic growth
of tools internally.
We try and choose and drive the
use of standards internally.
But, of course,
that is difficult.
With Inside DocuSign, we
have two productivity suites.
We have a good percentage of
our users who are on G Suite.
And we have a good
percentage of our users
who are on the Office Suite.
So what we try and do
is drive the solutions
that make things
easy to use, but also
allow us to drive the
standards and meet the security
and compliance initiatives
that we're subject to.
PRIYA PATEL: That's great.
And what are your key
priorities in terms
of security and compliance?
JOHN LAKE: To simply put it,
to be as secure as possible,
but also trying to strike the
right balance between security
and productivity.
Of course, DocuSign's
a trust brand.
We take security
incredibly seriously.
But we also are a
software company
that's trying to innovate
and drive new use
cases as quickly as possible.
So I think striking that balance
is incredibly important to us
to make sure that we do that
as effectively as possible.
PRIYA PATEL: And I
can imagine, you're
probably dealing with
some sensitive information
with legal contracts
and whatnot.
JOHN LAKE: Yeah.
Certainly DocuSign, again,
and being well known
as an e-signature company,
a lot of contracts,
a lot of transactional data
that's flowing through,
a lot of PII is stored
in this information.
And of course, we want to
maintain as much security
around that as possible.
PRIYA PATEL: Yeah.
And what were you using
before you started using
Box as your content platform?
JOHN LAKE: Yeah.
DocuSign has been a Box
customer for about five years,
a little over five years.
Prior to that, what a lot
of other folks were using,
right-- file servers distributed
around our different offices,
local connections,
and the things
that come along with that.
PRIYA PATEL: And so and in
terms of the Box for G Suite
integration, can you talk a bit
about how this new integration
is going to help solve
some challenges, help
add value to your
employees in the tools
that they're using everyday?
JOHN LAKE: Yeah.
Like I said, I think
we have about half
of our organization
that's running G Suite.
The other half is using O365.
I think one of the
challenges that we've had.
We've been, again, been a Box
customer for about five years.
But we've had great content
management on the back end
with Box.
We've had the enterprise-class
security, administration,
and content management tools
that come along with Box.
But of course, we haven't,
until now-- very recently-- been
able to apply those controls to
the percentage of our user base
that is running G Suite.
So I think coming along
with the G Suite connector
now, what we'll be able
to do is help drive
and facilitate a standard
content management back
end where we can take those
robust security, content
management, and
administration controls
that we've otherwise been
able to employ with O365
and be able to leverage
those with G Suite as well.
PRIYA PATEL: That's great.
So what aspect of
this new integration
are you most excited about?
JOHN LAKE: I think that aspect
that we just talked about,
which is that ability from
us, from internal enterprise
applications, IT perspective,
to be able to maintain
the visibility
and the governance
around the significant
amount of content
that's originated and
maintained in G Suite
as well as being able to apply
those same things, of course,
to O365.
But giving us that
single pane of glass,
that single ability to
drive that governance
from the IT perspective
versus having
to maintain two distinct
silos, where we've had
to do that in the past.
PRIYA PATEL: And I know that
you're a cloud-first company.
Are you using other cloud tools?
Are your employees
using other cloud tools
in their day-to-day today
to get their work done that
and you've integrated Box with
or that you're looking to?
JOHN LAKE: Yeah.
Yeah, we have.
Of course, we are a
cloud-first company.
And I think probably
the best example
of that is Salesforce is a
good workplace tool that's
used broadly across the
organization, integrates
with Box and, again,
gives us a way
to start driving better standard
content management behavior,
content management governance
through the back end.
PRIYA PATEL: That's great.
And for those of you who
are unfamiliar with how
the Salesforce integration
works with Box,
it essentially brings Box
directly into Salesforce.
So your sales reps can
easily access all their files
and folders directly from
the opportunity or record.
And so with that, I'd love to
open it up to the audience.
So stay tuned for
live Q&A for questions
for either me or John.
We'll be back in
less than a minute.
Hi, everybody.
Welcome back.
Before we go into the
audience questions,
I want to just provide
some information
on how to contact Box if you
have additional questions--
just a quick email
address you can email us
at with any questions
is sales@box.com.
If you're interested in the
beta of the Google Docs, Sheets,
and Slides integration,
the public beta
is available to anyone today.
You can go to this URL
that's listed here,
box.com/partner/google, and
there will be a link with
instructions for how you
can enable this beta.
And then, this will be generally
available to the public
by end of year.
So we hope that you are excited
to use this integration.
And I also want to highlight
that the Box for Gmail
add-on that I reviewed as well
will be available generally
to the public by end of year.
So with that, I'm going
to go ahead and take
our first question.
"Are Google Docs created on
Box accessible outside Box--
via Google Drive,
docs.google.com, et cetera?"
So no.
That's the great thing
about this integration
is that any docs that
are created in Box
are going to be managed
and secured in Box.
They won't be accessible
from any other place.
And this is-- so that IT--
I'm sure John recognizes
the importance of this,
and he talked about it--
can kind of centrally manage
everything in one place.
There's a question
for John, which
is, "You said you were
using on-premise content
solutions before.
How did you centralize
all of that onto Box?"
JOHN LAKE: Yeah.
It was not a quick exercise.
It's definitely not
the flip of a switch.
It's more the turn of
the knob over time.
And what we did is just we just
bit it off in small chunks.
I think one of the
first things we did
is we made sure
everybody is aware.
We Communicate out you
know what we're doing,
why we're doing it, what
the benefits and impact
to the organization
are by making
this move from an on-prem
storage solution to the cloud.
And then, of course,
we look for champions
around the organization.
As we start to deploy this, we
find and target good use cases
for this.
For us, internally,
as an example,
our marketing organization
did a lot of interaction
with external agencies.
So having a content
management system
where they could collaborate
internally, relatively
simply, easily, quickly
across platforms was great.
But then, of course, you have
a lot of input and feedback
from your external agencies.
So again, targeting
a good use case,
getting some early
quick wins with it
to build some momentum with it,
and then just staying adamant,
almost, about the
progression of rolling this
out and then turning down
and rolling off of those
file servers.
I think overall, over the
course of the execution,
we moved about-- a little over
40 terabytes worth of data
into Box.
PRIYA PATEL: That's great.
And that's actually--
you touched
upon something that comes
up a lot with customers
who have selected Box is that,
with their previous content
platforms, it's not so easy
to share files externally.
So as an example,
some customers who
might be using the
Office Suite, they
have to toggle between
OneDrive and SharePoint.
They have to use SharePoint
for external sharing, OneDrive
for internal sharing.
So that's great that
you highlighted that.
And then the other
thing you noted,
which also comes up
a lot, is the need
for change management
and to provide training
to your employees to drive
adoption of these tools.
I think Box is
very user-friendly,
as is DocuSign, as is G Suite.
But it's important to
have those early wins
as well to share
with your employees.
JOHN LAKE: Absolutely.
Totally agree.
PRIYA PATEL: So another
question that came in,
"Does this integration
requires a Google account?"
That's a great question.
This integration is available
to customers with paid G Suite
accounts.
So as long as you have
a paid G Suite account,
you're eligible to
use this integration,
and it's completely free.
"Can multiple users
simultaneously
edit a single document?"
Yes.
Absolutely.
That's one of the great
benefits of G Suite,
enabling that real-time
collaboration.
And so they can edit it.
They can resolve comments with
all changes saved into Box.
"Which Google editors
are included?"
Google Docs, Sheets, and Slides,
and as I mentioned and showed
in the demo, you can
actually convert Office files
into G Suite files,
and any edits
will be saved back into
the original file format.
And then, someone
is asking about how
to access the public beta.
So the public beta, if you
go to box.com/partner/google,
there will be a link to be
able to sign up for the beta.
But it will be generally
available to the public
by end of year, which is great.
Because anyone will be able
to-- if you're a Box admin--
you can just enable it
in your admin console.
OK.
Those are all of the questions.
Stay tuned for the next session,
Extending Google's Grab and Go
Program to Your Business.
John, thank you for joining us.
It was a pleasure.
JOHN LAKE: Thank you.
PRIYA PATEL: Thank
you, everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]